je les
enchaînnais je les
cagoulais je les mettais dans les
camions 30 ou 40 personnes par camion je
ne savais jamais où on allait les
emmener il y avait ou ne9 personnes pour
exécutter les
prisonniers il nous attendaient sur
place et comme il n'était pas nombreux
on leur donnait un coup demain 30 ans
après ils vont devoir répondre de leur
crime c'est au Cambodge dans le box les
anciens dirigeantsmer rouge ils sont
coupables d'avoir organisé ou couvert un
génocide parmi les plus meurtriers de
l'histoire bilan 2 millions de morts
match magazine a rencontré l'un des
principaux dirigeants du régime de Poul
pote Kie sampan pour la première fois
l'ancien président du campucha
démocratique a accepté d'être filmé chez
lui dans quelques mois il sera devant un
tribunal pour s'expliquer sur le rôle
qu'il a joué dans le génocide lors du
procès il il sera défendu par son ami
l'avocat du diable Jacques Verges ancien
défenseur du nazi Klaus Barb nous avons
suivi vergess dans ce voyage retour au
Cambodge où les rumeurs disent qu'il y a
passé clandestinement quelques années à
l'époque descmer rougge il revient pour
aider que sampan son vieux camarade de
la Sorbonne les deux hommes sont restés
fidèles à leur conviction pas de regret
et une haine commune celle de l'Amérique
un reportage de Grégoire deot et
[Musique]
aéroport de pomen dimanche 18 janvier ce
sont les premières images de Jac verg au
Cambodge c'est longtemps que vous n'étiz
pas venu au
Cambodge très
longtemps en des temps
immémoriaux la légende jamais vérifiée
mais largement entretenue par l'avocat
lui-même veut qu'il est séjourné ici
entre 1970 et
1978 une zone d'ombre dans la vie de
Jacques vergess qui correspond à une des
périodes les plus sanglantes de
l'histoire du pays celle de l'avènement
du régime mer Rouge
années de marche forcé vers le
communisme pay
rééducation politique de masse abolition
de la monnaie exode forcé vers les
campagnes et surtout purge
sanglante 1700000 morts en moins de 3
ans un génocide aux yeux de la
communauté
internationale 25 ans après un tribunal
s'apprête à juger les principaux
dirigeants rouge encore vivants parmi
eux sampan l'ancien président du camp
démocratique il vit aujourd'hui dans le
nord du pays à Paine à 200 m de la
frontière thaïlandaise c'est un vieil
ami de Jacques
verg on se
retrouve le voyage ça fait 24 he
déjà sans
interruption mais tant qu'on a la
jeunesse c'est le moment de parler de la
jeunesse
oui depuis 5 ans Kie sampan vit reclu au
milieu des derniers combattants mer
Rouge dans cette maison un ancien centre
d'éducation politique accusé de crime
contre l'humanité k sampan a demandé
l'aide de Jacques vergess et l'a
immédiatement obtenu en souvenir de leur
idéal communiste nous sommes dans le
monde un certain nombre de gens à nous
être reconnu il y a 10 20 30 40 50
ans nous êtes
reconnu mobilisé avec le même
idéal cha vécu des aventures
différentes certains ont déserté mais
ceux qui sont restés
fidèles à cette
idéal qui on con l'honneur l'honneur de
soi on est une immense fratie dans le
monde et quand quelqu'un à Paris à Paris
les nouvelles arrive quelqu'un me dit tu
sais un tel est en
danger qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
lui
on a un g de sympathie il vous répond on
décide de se revoir et puis on décide de
se se battre un très grand mot de lutter
ensemble après le procès je
serai
blanchi et pour pourrai
redevenir un homme comme les
autres
Jacques vergess et queampan leur amitié
a commencé il y a plus de 50 ans sur les
bans de la Sorbonne deux intellectuels
idéalistes convaincus que le capitalisme
vivait alors ces dernières
heures ils vont militer ensemble au sein
du Parti communiste français à l'époque
le seul parti a osé se déclarer
ouvertement
anticolonialiste si j'ai participé au
manifestations contre la guerre du
Vietnam et contre la guerre
Algérie c'est moins par
idéologie que par patriotisme je
pensais à mon pays à la
victoire même
différé on avait fait un jour une
manifestation dans la cour de la
Sorbonne contre la guerre du Vietnam je
sais pas si vous vous rappelez et là il
y
avait t tous nos amis
mais il y avait également des types du
corps expéditionnaire en costume
militaire décidé à la
BAGAR on s livr à des discours
enflammés et à la fin quand ils ont
voulu attaquer on a chanté la
Marseillaise il se sont mis au gardeavou
tandis qu'on les regarda en disant
contre nous de la tyrannie
les
que la sang impure
impure après avoir quitté Paris devenu
député et journaliste va fuir la
capitale pour rester fidèle à ses idéaux
c'est en 1967 au fond de la jungle qu'il
va découvrir l'idéologique mer Rouge
sures images il est à côté du prince
norodoman garant de la tradition
cambodgenne comme lui se mettre sous la
protection du nouveau chef de la
résistance qui a pris en quelques mois
le contrôle d'un tiers du pays une
révélation pour kampan qui décide
d'aider le seul homme selon lui capable
d'offrir l'indépendance au Cambodge mais
surtout de préserver son unité nationale
cet homme vénéré comme un véritable dieu
par ses fidèles c'est Paul pote il s'est
autoproclamé frère numéro 1 et il le
restera jusqu'à sa mort en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poul potte incarne un nouveau système ne
souffrant aucune contradiction un
système où il faut briser l'homme ancien
détruire l'identité individuelle pour ne
pas remettre en cause la marche de
l'histoire vers le collectivisme pour y
parvenir les Rouges ont utilisé la
rééducation la privation de nourriture
la délation la
torture je voulais vous faire une image
pipole et pu vous avait
raté c'était quoi votre image pipel
cuueillir cette fleur mais je l'ai pas
raté du tout moi
aussi monsieur le Président je vous
l'offre c'est pas encore le muget non
que sampan va être adopté par les
paysans que mer Rouge mais à leurs yeux
et surtout aux yeux de poulpte il sera
toujours considéré comme un intellectuel
bourgeois plutôt qu'un révolutionnaire
un état d'esprit peut apprécié dans le
Maqui et c'est Paul pote en personne qui
se chargera de le rééduquer
l'école son c'était à côté c'était à
côté un peu il est un peu sévère il faut
bien
l'avouer parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
doit s'occuper de l'hydrologie c'est
normal de sa part il essaie
de de profiter de chaque occasion pour
transformer en intellectuel
en un paysan pa vous le reprochez
ça on peut pas dire utiliser le mot
reprocher
critiquer aider
à acquérir une position de classe
voilà au début des années 70 les
bombardements massifs américains au
Vietnam vont très vite déborder sur le
Cambodge le territoire contrôlé par
lesquers rouges sert de base de repli au
Viet Kong les indépendantistes
vietnamiens il y aura des dizaines de
milliers de morts des deux côtés de la
frontière une émotion qui va provoquer
une déferlante pacifiste dans le monde
entier et précipiter le départ des
Américains à l'époque alors que l'échec
de la politique américaine dans la
région est consommé les kmerers rouges
eux sont encore perçus comme des
libérateurs dans leur pays et un peu
partout en Occident c'est cela que
Jacques Verget entend rappeler à la
barre pour nier la spécificité du
génocide CER rouge et du même coup la
responsabilité politique de son ami k
sampan les médias peuvent servir à la
contre-attaque de la
vérité bien sûr je serai accusé on on
prétendra m'avoir vu AB en train de en
pyjama noir en train de couper des têtes
bien sûr qu'on le dira mais moi je sais
il pas besoin de photo et de témoin ce
que les Américains ont
fait au Cambodge le coup d'État
militaire qu'ils ont organisé
on peut pas ignorer ce qu'ils ont fait
au Vietnam bombarder des forêts entières
avec des défoliants qui aujourd'hui
encore font que des enfants naissent
handicapés le 17 avril
1975 malgré les bombardements américains
lesmer rougge entent en vainqueur d'nom
Pen l'Amérique déjà défite au Vietnam
voit son dernier soutien dans la région
tombé sous les coups de bout mer Rouge
ce jour-là le régime proaméricain de lol
qui tient encore P Pen est
renversé Paul po vient de mettre un
terme à 5 années de guerre civile image
symbole de la fin d'un conflit qui a
occupé pendant 5 ans les écrans de
télévision du monde entier tout le monde
à l'époque croit à la paix enfin
retrouvé mais l'euphorie sera de courte
durée la révolution imaginée par Frère
numéro 1 va passer à la vitesse
supérieure en quelques heures les rares
témoins étrangers journalistes ou
diplomates encore présents dans Pnom Pen
sont expulsés de la capitale B Paul pot
décrète l'année zéro d'une nouvelle ère
et ses combattants entament l'évacuation
brutale et totale de tous les habitants
des ville vers les
campagnes en 5 jours la capitale
cambodgienne qui compte alors 3200000
habitants est vidé par la force
elle devient une ville fantôme dans
toutnom Pen il reste moins de 10000
habitants tout a été abandonné sur place
les les voitures détruites c'est à ce
moment-l que kampan réalise pour la
première fois le fossé qui le sépare des
rouges et de popte les premiers jours où
nous entrions à
P je me suis
ouver à lui pour
lui dire tous mes
sentiments à la fois de regret pour les
décisions prises
et de
préoccupation pour les idéologues
merrouges la ville est une structure
impropre à la société qu'ils veulent
bâtir et toute l'énergie révolutionnaire
doit aller au campagne des millions de
personnes sont jetées sur les routes
l'homme nouveau doit rompre avec son
passé les instituteurs les médecins
doivent renier leur savoirs les couples
doivent être séparés les mères doivent
laisser leurs enfants aux mains des
éducateurs politiques dès qu'ils ont
l'âge de marcher et de
comprendre pourtant kampan ne tournera
pas le dos à ses compagnons de route il
acceptera même le poste de président du
campuchcia démocratique pendant plus de
3 ans il servira de vitrine à l'étranger
offrant l'image d'un homme modéré mais
plus personne ne saura ce qui se passe
réellement à l'intérieur du pays la
monnaie est abolie et tous les
Cambodgiens doivent rejoindre les
coopératives à la campagne et participer
aux énormes projets d'irrigation
toute la population est mobilisée pour
restructurer l'économie agricole
dévastée par la guerre les travailleurs
des villes deviennent des paysans et à
l'inverse les rouges transformment de
jeunes fermiers en ouvriers ils veulent
ainsi créer une nouvelle classe
prolétaire intégralement
soumise cette révolution socialiste
poussée à l'extrême et l'uvre de Paul
pot frère numéro 1 édicte les nouvelles
règles de vie une à une que est à ses
côté il croit encore que Paul pot était
animé par une seule conviction le bien
de son
pays on le voyait bien
indispensable à la tête des rouges de la
résistance de la Parti camboutier
démocratique de la coalition
tripartite mais tout d'un coup
C
des CRIM ou des fautes
que je comprends
plus c'est pas seulement
moi qui pense ainsi mais
seulement tous les autres leadersain
rouge on évite
de
parler de quoi que ce soit qui
puisse
diviser qui puisse semer la division ou
la confusion dans ns rang ceci dans le
souci de
pouvoir
résister toute contestation entraî la
peine de mort le régime sombre alors
dans la folie répressive les écoles ne
servant plus à rien elles sont
transformé en prison et en centre de
torture ce lycée au centre de Pom que
les rou appel S21 a vu passer plus de
14000 prisonniers aujourd'hui c'est un
musée de
l'horreur
van est l'un des tris seuls survivants
de S21 il témoignera au procès des
dirigeants mer
Rouge CR que
j'entendais et que j'entends encore
cétait un grand désespoir et ça reste
encore dans mes
oreilles après le départ des rou m à
pere sans s'arrêter pour êre s de ne
rien oublier et surtout pour que les
générations futures et le monde entier
connaiss la vérité rouge
quand j'étais dans cette pièce j'étais
enchaîné comme
eux ça je l'ai dessiné en
1980 quand on it on avait les yeux
bandés et et quand on nous enlevait le
bandeau et que nous étions bien
enchaînés il tapit sur le tableau noir n
dire de le
lire il disait que ceux qui savent lire
lisent pour les
autres le premier point c'était qu'il
était interdit de parler même si on se
connaissait il était interdit de parler
il fallait toujours demander
l'autorisation au gardien on avait
aucune
liberté c'était le règlement de la
prison
on était tous couchés si on voulait
s'asseoir il fallait demander
l'autorisation ne fais pas l'imbécile
car tu es l'homme qui s'oppose à la
Révolution répond immédiatement à ma
question sans prendre le temps de
réfléchir pendant la bastonnade ou
l'électrochoc il est interdit de crier
fort si vous ne suivez pas tous les
ordres cdessus vous recevrez des coups
de bâton de fils électriqu et des
électrochocs vous ne pourrez pas compter
ces
coups vous savez on va se rendre compte
que ce ne sont pas des centaines mais
des milliers des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont mortes
ici tous ceux qui rentré dans ce
bâtiment était considéré comme des
traîtres à la Révolution par les rouges
tout était planifié chaque nouvel
arrivant photographié numéroté la
torture servait à faire avouer des
crimes imaginaires justifiant les
exécutions tout devait se faire dans
l'ordre et la
discipline tous ces gens sont
morts aucun survivant ils sont tous
morts
elle elle é attrapé le 10 décembre
78 un jour elle est entré dans ma
cellule c'était une camarade
combattante a éé Captur
10c8 elle doit être morte moins de 3
semaines après que je l'ai vu que le 7
janvier quand l'armée vietnamienne est
arrivée il n'y avait plus que des
cadavres qui ont été ensuite
enterré pendant ces années de prison van
était le sculpteur au service du
pouvoir le directeur de la
prison nous répétait qu'il fallait que
ce soit
ressemblant cétait une question de vie
ou de
ma vie ne tenait qu'à
ça seul sujet de ces sculptur Paul pote
le chef suprême le culte de la
personnalité est à son
apogé à cette époque je ne pensais pas à
grandchose je ne faisais que travailler
pour ne pas mourir
pour revoir ma
femme mes
enfants et même si Paul pote avait fait
emprisonn et tuer des
gens ces scultures que je faisais étit
l'unique moyen pour moi de
survivre les historiens vous prê cette
phrase en
1977 nous devons exterminer l'ennemi
tout doit être fait à fond avec ordre on
estime au moment où vous prononcez cette
phrase monsieur le Président on on a
déjà atteint un million de morts au au
Cambodge c'était des déclarations
officielles et en tant que tel je ne
pouvais pas
ignorer ce
que penser le leer k rouge le slogans de
leader
rou moi je sais seulement qu'il était
chef de
l'État s dit qu'il ne sait
pas dans ce cas là moi aussi je ne sais
[Musique]
rien
dans la maison de pailine la discrétion
est de rigueur pour l'instant que sampan
ne veut pas officialiser sa décision de
prendre Jacques vergess comme défenseur
en ville personne n'est au courant de la
présence de l'avocat parisien
oui mais il peuent
surprendre à tout à l'heure vous
disparaissez maître je disparais
à l'arrivée de chaque visiteur Jacques
vergess regagne la chambre d'ami que
kampan lui a réservé le dernier occupant
avant lui n'était autre que Paul
pote kampan a longtemp ni l'existence de
cette répression à grande échelle mais à
l'proche de son procès il veut
s'expliquer il va jusqu'à recevoir des
victimes chez lui ce médecin a perdu son
père et sa mère dans les cand
deéducation lui aussi veut comprendre
vous savez les gens ils ne comprennent
pas ils n'arrivent pas à se convaincre
qu'au poste où vous étiez vous ignoriez
les événements mes amis me demandent qui
est-ce qui était au poste de dirigeant
c'était que s pourquoi n'était-il pas au
courant à cette époque tout le monde
devait respecter les règles on ne
pouvait même pas aller voir ses proches
qui étaient à côté ce n'était même pas
possible de rendre visite à sa famille
vous le savez ça c'est ce que j'ai
entendu
dire
exactement ne dites pas toute la
vérité que vous cachez certaines choses
que vous cachez votre
responsabilité avant eux et leur famille
ils vous aimaient
beaucoup mais leur famille leur père
leur mère ont été
massacré massacré durant les événements
ou
et maintenant ils sont déçus n'est-ce
pas quand
j' j'avais un
périmètre qui s'app le secteur A3 Auel
duquel je ne pouvais même pas
[Musique]
sortir ce secteur
a3é direct du comité central d'EM rouge
vous voyez je devais respecter les
ordres et donc je ne sortais pas c'est
parce que j'étais enfermé dans ce
périmètre que je ne savais rien de la
situation du pays comment pouvais-je
savoir les visiteurs s'en vont pas
forcément
convaincus le médecin attendra le procès
pour se faire une réelle
opinion vous avez pu suivre un peu les
j'ai suivi un
peu
vous sortez votre cachette
je attention t ah oui oh pardon je
regarder à un moment je suis sorti il y
avait quelqu'un qui prenait des notes là
c'était qui c'est de de deux personnes
visiteurs ah oui je
regardé parce que comme je vous
entendais remercier sans arrêt merci
vous montrez beaucoup de courage je dis
bon c'est
fini
sont des gens qui qui s'expriment en
disant qu' sont pas forcément tout à
fait d'accord donc qui est inér est bien
des gens qui sont pas d'accord
forcment mais pas point deu
plus la communication
respect autes personnes à travers lui
qui voudrait
demander la permission de venir
discuter impossible de se déplacer à
l'intérieur du Cambodge sans rencontrer
des victimes toutes les familles
cambodgienes ont souffer pendant les
années rou dans cette maison c'est le
père de famille qui a survécu à une
année de
torture il me
frapp il me frapp avec des câbles
électriques
me tortur à
l'électricité il me frappa pour que
j'avoue n'importe
quoi il frapp avec
quoi avec une barre de fer de cette
taille
tous les jours était un prétexte pour
frapper pour tuer il
frappait il y a eu des milliers de
morts des gens ont été tués devant moi à
mes
pieds comment avez-vous
survécu ils m'ont battu à mort mais l'un
des gardiens m'a sauvé la vie bon pe
voy la victime sauvé par son bourreau le
bourreau devenant à son tour victime les
C rouges ont réussi à les rendre
indissociables et dans le même village
25 ans après les faits ils n'ont d'autre
joie que de cohabiter mung travaillait à
S21 seule défense il n'avait pas le
choix je savais qu'il y avait des
tortures même si je n'y assistais pas il
ne me laissait pas voir ce qu'il faisait
au
prisonniers les gardiens les
tortionnaires c'est bien
distinct il était gardien et son
principal boulot consistait à emmener
les prisonniers sur le lieu de leur
exécution
je les
enchaînnais je les
cagoulais je les mettais dans les
camions 30 ou 40 personnes par camion je
ne savais jamais où on allait les
emmener il y avait ou ne personnes pour
exécuter les
prison il nous attendait sur place et
comme il n'était pas nombreux
on leur donnait un coup de
main moi je notait le nombre de
personnes tuées et le chef s'asseit et
regardait on les enterrait et nous on
rapport les chaînes et si je me trompais
dans les comptes j'étais
responsable ce qu'il comptait c'était
des hommes des femmes et beaucoup
d'enfants fils d'instituteur de
commerçant
des gamins des villes juste coupable
d'exister et de ne pas être né
paysan tout ce que j'ai fait c'est parce
que j'y étais
contraint les bourreaux me demandaient
de leur montrer que je pouvais moi aussi
tuer des gens comme ça spontanément
devant
eux à ce moment-là je ne faisait que
frapper je demandais au prisonniers de
s'agenouiller et je lui donnais un coup
de barre de fer derrière la
tte il tombait dans la fuse et le groupe
de tueurs terminit le
travail il voyait comme cela que j'étais
fidèle au pouvoir
rouge dans votre quotidien vous vous
souvenez encore de cette
période non dans ce CASL je ne m'en
souviens pas c'est quand on me
questionne que les souvenirs reviennent
vous faites des
cauchemars non mes souvenirs me hentent
pas au départ des queers rouges des
fausses communes ont été découvertes à
travers tout le
pays nous savons très bien que c'était
des gens propres
désintéressés animés par un idéal prêt à
sacrifier leur vie et même les
critiquant sur certains aspects de de ce
qu'ils ont fait nous ne pouvons pas les
traiter comme comme une armée de sous
d'Ar violent pillant et
senrichissant
j'ignoris le caractère massif des crimes
dénoncés et c'est pour ça
que moi je continue à
considérer que le
mouvement
est
réellement
patriotique ce n'est pas l'avis des
responsables du centre de documentation
du
Cambodge yukchong est l'archiviste du
génocide il se prépare pour le procès et
a déjà rassemblé près de 400000
documents qui seront versés comme pièce
à conviction Yong ne croit pas à
l'innocence de kampan le président du
campucha démocratique vivait dans le
secteur réservé au dirigeants du parti
il y travaillait aussi plus précisément
au bureau
0 en fait le cœur du pouvoir rouge en
charge notamment du centre de torture
S21 mais nous avons des documents qui
prou qu'il Savit ce qui se pass à
l'époque des
rouge regarde ce c'est un document enyé
au bureau 870 ce sont des rapports
venant de la base des comités locaux et
envoyés à
870 bon disons que kampan ne dirigeait
pas ce bureau mais il était là il était
au courant des incidents dans les
villages il sait comment manipuler
l'esprit
d'mer et il utilise ça depuis des années
pour tenter de fuir ses
responsabilités concernant toute la
période d'cmer rouge
au procès queampan continuera d'affirmer
n'avoir eu connaissance des massacres
qu'à partir de
1999 la seule chose qu'il est
aujourd'hui prête à assumer c'est le
travail forcé imposé à des centaines de
milliers de ses
compatriotes T c faites
là que j'ai coné que considéré comme des
sacrifices
inévitables on parle du du travail forcé
mais il y a aussi ce travail idéologique
qui est fait c'est-à-dire de faire
rentrer de force cette idéologie dans le
crâne des des en général on n'ait pas
vraiment le choix où on devenait mer
Rouge où on était éliminé si vous posez
la
question tel que vous le
posez tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire cette méthode qui
consiste à ne pas laisser le
choix à
l'intéresser alors là dans ce cas je
peux pas
approuver
mais j'approuve les
efforts déployés par les dirigeants coin
rougees
pour
informer la masse paysane de la
situation du
pays sur les cours d'éducation politique
il faut pas voir ça comme un lavage de
cerveau toute organisation
politique a un intérêt et un devoir
d'expliquer sa position et sa vision du
monde en ce moment si nous prenons la
France chaque tous les étés les les
journaux sont remplis à propos des
université d'été le Parti socialiste
Essie de faire
admettre son sa conception du social
réformisme le Front national essaie de
faire accepter ces conception du
nationalisme d'extrême droite ou de
droite
comme l'UMP essaie de faire comprendre
et répandre ses idées c'est une chose
parfaitement normale
reprocher au rouge c'est quand même de
où on était d'accord où on était
emprisonné voir éliminé non là ce n'est
pas vrai ce n'est pas ex ça parce que
autrement en dehors de l'armée mer Rouge
tout le monde aurait été en prison CIT
pas possible les mer rouges combataient
ceux qu'il considéraent à ts ou à raison
comme les ennemis de leur action mais
non pas ceux qui qui n'étaient ni pour
ni contre en 4 ans de pouvoir ils ont
tué plus d'un million de personnes et
brisé des millions de vies dit que
aujourd'hui la majorité des Cambodgiens
a besoin de ce procès alors là je compte
aller
au faire les démarches officielles avoir
accès aux archives et tout ça est-ce que
je devrais vous accompagner
à on verra à ce
moment l'attitude des
autorité sinon je pour les c'est ici et
vous allez vous moi je vais là-bas puis
je vous rends compte he je reviens je
vous rends
compte si que sampan préfère éviter de
se rendre à Pnom Pen c'est à cause d'un
douloureux
souvenir à la faveur d'un accord de paix
signé avec le gouvernement le 27
novembre
1991 il revient dans la capitale des
milliers de personnes l'attendent
elles ont décidé de le
lyncher
à gauche la chemise et le crâne en sent
que s P plus ou moins bien protégé par
l'armée n'a plus qu'une solution prendre
la
fuite
il ne sera resté que quelques heures
dans la capitale une bonne partie de la
population de pnompen n'est pas prête à
pardonner est un mort
vivant il est VI mais mentalement il est
mort je ve dire idéologiquement il sait
qu'il a
perdu mais en tantêtre humain il a aussi
peur
sauverou il sait que le monde entier est
contre
lui et maintenant vous c'est le seul
endroit où vous sentez en
sécurité où je me sens entouré
d'amitié pas les anciens
combattants votre voisin est également
un ancien responsable rouge oui
monur numéro 2 é chargé par de la mise
en application de l'idéologique mer
Rouge aujourd'hui il ne sort plus jamais
de sa maison et ne reçit que ses
fidèles lui multip les rencontres
aujourd'hui ce sont d'anci rou qui lu
rend visite celui éta commissaire
politique
américain laissé par les
Américains
comb c'est les
Vietnamiens moi j'ai été blessé en
72 celui éta soldat chef de groupe comme
ses camarades il est contre l'idée même
d'un
procès moii je ne veux pas de ce
procès je pense que la plupart des
Cambodgiens ne le souhaitent pas non
plus mais le tribunal est en train de
s'organiser je pense que le
tribunal va me
convoquer
le plus important c'est que les cambodji
so
en alorsils sont en pourquoi r les
divisions du
passé cela va provoquer encore des
guerres le tribunal veut faire un procès
et à d'autres personnes mais il est
vieux à quoi ça
sert tout ce que je veux moi c'est la
paix c'est tout ce que je veux
dire après la visite au président ceux
qui se revendiquent toujours comme étant
mer Rouge vont saluer n leur véritable
chef si les anciens combattants entrent
facilement que s doit toujours demander
la permission pour avoir une audience
avec frère numéro
2 c'est bon tu peux
venir et les
journalistes c'est bon qu'il viennent
c'est la première fois qu'il accepte de
parler à des
journalistes toujours aussi respecté ne
regrette
[Musique]
rien en tant qu'ancien combattant je
viens prendre de vos
nouvelles actuellement je vous le dis
franchement je vis
paisiblement s trop me préoccuper au
jour le jour dans la
simplicité
j'ai 78
ans mais la santé n'est pas
fondamentale le plus
important c'est que mon esprit reste
intact et que l'amour du pays reste
intact
comme est accusé de crime contre
l'humanité mais s de son fait il
n'emploa pas la même tactique que son
voisin qu'z-vous dire au tribunal qui
vous
convoquera
premièrement mon souhait que le
tribunal soit
compétent soit
impartial et soit
juste allez-vous vous faire représenter
par un
avocat je pense que ceux qui ont
participé au mouvement comprennent la
situation
pas alors je préfère éclaircir tous ces
événements
compliqués en leur
expliquantiême et sans
avocat comment allez-vous faire pour
vous défendre des
crimes que l'on vous accuse d'avoir
commis je n'irai pas au tribunal pour
dissimuler la
vérité car c'est mon devoir en tant que
citoyen et son pays de dire la
vérité mais j'irai pour éclairer le
peuple et la communauté
internationale pour qu'il comprenn qui
sont les ennemis du
Cambodge qui a tué le
Cambodge la ligne politique du campucia
démocratique n'était pas de tuer son
peuple mais de protéger le
pays ce sont les B52 américains qui ont
tué des moines des femmes enceintes des
enfants même les fourmis les fourmis
rouges les vers de terre les cocotiers
les palmiers qui sont innocents c'est ça
que je veux
dire c'est ça que je veux dire au
journalistes pour qu'ils éclairent la
communauté
internationale et si jamais le tribunal
osait condamner les cers rouges c'est
comme si les Américains se frappaient
eux-mêmes avec une hache ils seraient
contraint de s'accuser et donc de se
condamner
eux-mêmes en tout cas s'il devait y
avoir de nouvelles invasions étrangères
et que je pouvais encore tenir une arme
je combattrais
encore pour protéger ma nation mon
peuple dans la perspective du procès que
sampan tient à se démarquer de frère
numéro 2 mais comme son avocat
aujourd'hui encore il refuse de le
condamner et c'est un homme intéressant
sans
doute évidemment il exprime son opinion
personnelle en tant
que un des dirigeants du
mouvement je ne sais pas
sil vraiment il s'en rendent
compte tout ça n'empêche pas Nicolas que
la Commune n'est pas morte ils l'ont tué
à coup de chassepau à coup de
mitrailleuse et roulé avec son drapeau
dans la terre argileuse tout ça
n'empêche pas Nicolas que la Commune
n'est pas
morte s'ils sont jugés coupables nunch
et kosampan risque la prison à
perpétuité la peine de mort a été abolie
en 1993 au Cambodge